hey everybody i'm dave rubin it's the
reuben report direct message for today
february 18 2022
we are live streaming on rumble youtube
and blaze tv subscribe share there's a
notification bell etc
and today we are doing a reuben report
locals community q a we got a couple
dozen questions here they're all over
the map i'm gonna do my best to answer
them honestly and forthrightly with a
little bit of humor and perhaps some
snark but before we get to that i
realized that this whole week we barely
talked about joe biden you guys know joe
biden he's the elderly man that's
pretending to be president of the united
states and he didn't really do that much
this week and i was talking to the guys
and i said people miss that old man you
know like is there something we could do
with that old man at the top of the q a
that would remind everybody what a great
handle he has on the issues of the day
and how he is truly the one running the
show video brock and i think it's a
right
for people that have valid healthcare
for people that have valid healthcare my
son's business dealings we're not
anything where everybody that he's
talking about i'll need an effective
strategy to mobilize true international
under pressure true and international
under pressure true and international
depression we've now hit
nine million cases nationwide you know
how i know how hard it is look
tomorrow's superstar
tuesday and i want to thank you all
i tell you what i'm rushing ahead aren't
i
we hold these truths to be self-evident
all men and women created by the go you
know the you know the thing i watch what
happened when the kids from parkland
marched up to and i i i met with them
and then they went off to up on the hill
when i was vice president they went off
the hill to go into those neighborhoods
all those congressmen were like no i'm
not here i'm not here
don't tell them i'm around we are
we choose unity over division we choose
science over fiction we choose truth
over facts words that stun the nation
and i would argue i know shocked the
world international leaders spoke about
it you had people like margaret that
excuse me you had
people like the former chairman and
leader of the party in in germany
you had angela merkel we have this
notion that somehow if you're poor you
cannot do it
poor kids are just as bright and just as
talented as white kids
wealthy kids black kids
asian kids i never believed we'd have to
fight this hard though i never believed
it to be this much in jeopardy
we launched our campaign
over on
the oval back in 29 may 19 2019
but you know what i said then we've been
through a lot since then what i said
then
is even more true today covert has taken
this year
just since the outbreak
has taken more than 100 years look
here's the lives
it's just it's when you think about it i
come out of the black community in terms
of my support if you notice i have more
people supporting me in the black
community than announced for me the only
african-american woman that ever been
elected to the united states senate a
whole range of people my point is true
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
and we're going to create a new bio
based manufacturing multi manufacturing
job
uh environment to deal farmers in on the
benefits of a changing economy one of
the things that that uh
um that the the leader of the united
states senate the speaker i mean the
house the speaker of the house you got
more questions but i tell it if you have
a problem figuring out whether you're
for me or trump and you ain't black
that was actually a 47 hour compilation
video that uh was just cut down to that
two minutes or so we were all laughing
hysterically throughout all of that uh
the two favorites i think amongst all of
us here and i'm sure you at home have
your own we choose truth over facts the
way he yells it with such certainty you
know that one and then poor kids are
just as bright and talented as white
kids that's a good one and then there's
one person in the back like
may god help us all all right let's get
to some questions ryan says what can be
done to counter the left taking credit
for the ending of the pandemic so i've
been talking about this a lot because
we're watching the shift happen in real
time you can feel it it's like we had
the omicron variant in december into
january pretty much everyone got coveted
who was going to get coveted it became
much milder most people weren't dying we
never saw the overloaded hospitals all
of that stuff
and then suddenly now the democrats are
looking pretty stupid i mean if you were
paying attention they should have been
looking pretty stupid for a long time
but they're suddenly realizing oh man
you know people don't like being put in
masks all the time they're they're upset
that their kids are still in masks two
years later people don't like all this
mandate stuff people don't like the
businesses shut down the lockdowns
people like the depression and all the
stuff that's happening everywhere so you
can feel it what they're doing right now
as they're sort of rolling the openings
throughout the states and i don't know
how they're going to do it but they're
going to do it right in front of our
eyes before these midterm elections
because they're going oh people don't
like us they're looking at the polling
all of the polling everywhere i mean
there's almost no poll that is counter
to this
it is completely showing a massive red
wave and as i keep saying you don't want
to get overconfident like obviously i
want a red wave i want some semblance of
freedom to wash across the country and
that will come through the republicans
although the republicans often ain't
great i accept that and admit that true
yes absolutely but they're a hell of a
lot better than the democrats right
but the democrats are seeing the polling
and they're going what can we do so
suddenly they're opening up they're you
know trying to ease up on masks but in
some cases they're not fully doing it
right we know what's going on in new
york where hoechul still has those kids
in masks it's it's very confusing and
conflated and each state is left to its
own device which is good right that's
federalism you all know that um but
they're gonna do it right in front of
our eyes they're gonna pull a magic
trick
so that by the end of the summer and
early fall as we're really ramping up
into this midterm thing they are going
to somehow trick
60 of the people to think that they were
the ones that wanted to open up the
entire time and it was the republicans
locking down you're going to watch the
media do it
god only knows what other tricks you
know they'll be able to pull and and
maybe biden will get his war in ukraine
and that'll distract people from what
happened or or just you just never know
right you never know in real life plus
you never know in this
constructed reality that we're all sort
of living in at this point so the
important thing and that's why i've been
doing the shows the way i've been doing
them over the last couple weeks is we
have to remember how we got here we have
to remember the people who dragged us
into this abyss the people who lied
along the way whether it's the cdc
director or fouchy or rachel maddow or
joe biden or whoever we have to remember
who did it and why did they do it
because they wanted to control us and
then remember who was trying to free us
the whole time i by the way i'm a
citizen of the free state of florida and
uh that has a little something to do
with the guy that's in charge here more
on that in just a moment jude says hi
dave i would really like to learn more
about cryptocurrency could you do a show
on it maybe have an expert speak on it
love your show yes absolutely look
especially in light of what's going on
in canada right now where we know that
they're seizing bank accounts literally
right this very second as i am speaking
to you they are seizing bank accounts of
people who made minor donations to
crowdfunding platforms uh to help out
the truckers so
the importance of crypto the idea of
decentralized payments right that don't
go through a bank that are peer-to-peer
you to someone else to exchange commerce
freely your goods and services for their
money without the middleman without the
big banks without government
interference like this is obviously the
future of the internet and by the way
it's not just decentralized payments
it's decentralized servers and making
sure that you can't just be shut down
because amazon aws doesn't like you like
how they blew up parlor right it's all
of these things a decentralized future
which by the way there's risks in
decentralization too because once
something's decentralized the whole
point of it is that it can't be taken
down well there's bad i mean like truly
evil bad stuff that is out there that
once you decentralize that now you've
got a problem so
there's no perfect system right we have
to think about all of these things and i
assure you as i'm in meetings with the
guys over at rumble and locals and we're
discussing all these things like we're
talking about all of these issues from
legal perspective and philosophical
perspective and a moral perspective and
everything else so the answer to your
question absolutely yes uh i'm going to
get anthony pompliano on who's a huge
bitcoin guy here in miami i actually did
his podcast which you could check out we
talk a little bit more about sort of my
feelings about crypto which i think you
can get a sense on also i had alex lloyd
on a couple of months ago who was a
co-writer of the little bitcoin book and
we go into sort of bitcoin 101. uh but
yeah i should be doing more on this for
sure because it's one of those things i
always talk about solutions it's like
one of the solutions to the mess right
now is is going through crypto is going
more decentralized uh so absolutely
appreciate the question uh nathan says
hey from atlanta has clyde been able to
go for a swim and do the doggy paddle
yet in florida so we do have a pool in
the backyard clyde has not got in the
pool yet because a couple times in l.a
we got him in the pool and about three
times we got him in two out of the three
times he ended up with an ear infection
after he's got the floppy ears and dogs
with the floppy ears i guess the ear
doesn't dry quite properly water stays
in the ear canal and then they get itchy
it gets kind of stinky you know that dog
ear stink you guys know about that it's
a yeah you know about the state it's
pretty it's pretty bad
um but i would like to get him to swim
like truly train him to swim which by
the way if you have a dog in a pool or
you got a cat in a pool i guess it's
hard to train a cat to swim but you
should because you know if the dog god
forbid ever fell in the pool you want
them to know which way to get out know
where the stairs are the shallow end et
cetera et cetera uh so we'll we'll get
him in there at some point uh and we've
taken him to the beach a couple times uh
ben says have you heard the rumor that
justin trudeau
is the son of fidel castro so this is
like the hot rumor online
connor do we have some images there we
go so that's justin trudeau on the left
that's a young
fidel castro uh next to him then of
course there's justin trudeau again and
then a slightly older fidel castro i
mean this is a real rumor that has been
going around for a long time as far as i
know it's not verified in any real way
but the nose looks like remarkably the
same and that bottom lip that's what it
is right the nose the bottom lip and
that smile that sort of half
slightly depressed smile uh no teeth
smile like there's something there and a
lot of people are saying it like
and it seems that their politics are
kind of lining up these days so maybe
like father like son i don't know if i
don't know if it's actually true but
trudeau's a bad dude i mean he's a bad
dude in case this whole week whatever i
was saying about trudeau didn't really
like seep into your pores he's just a
bad person he's he's deeply inauthentic
he came in for power
that's what he came in for
to guide canada to be more like how he
wanted it to be
not how the people wanted it to be and
at the end of every one of these people
who come in for power is the worst sort
of petty tyrant so he promised them
these rainbows he promised them
diversity and tolerance and now he
literally literally has troops out on
the street arresting people for
peacefully protesting the very same
people who said he's who he said we're
doing it because they have an irrational
fear of trans people there's your
rainbows for you uh bernie says did you
manage to convince candace to buy a
house near yours i think we've got an
image i had uh or we had candace owens
and her husband george over for dinner
last night that's where this question
comes from uh i just adore candace she's
just you know i know a lot of these
people that i talk to on camera or that
you know publicly or politicians or
whatever some of them are like one way
on camera and another way off camera and
candace probably more than anyone that
i've ever met in this space the candace
owens you see on camera is candace owens
period there is like no distinction
between private candice owens and public
candice owens i know a lot of people
that have you know a small divide in
some ways like it just it just is when
the camera's on you you you just are a
little bit different right and then some
people have a huge divide where the what
they present in front of the camera is
very different than actually what they
believe or how they act in their
personal life or something like that
and i'm not sitting here saying i'm the
perfect person uh but candace is is who
she is and we just had a wonderful
dinner last night actually was the first
time we had had a couple over for dinner
because we've been unpacking and getting
things in order and all that stuff so it
was really nice to have friends over uh
candace actually lives in nashville now
that's where the daily wire moved as you
know um i did look i was selling i sell
florida on everybody right although
florida really doesn't even need a
salesman if the proof is in the pudding
here uh or i guess the proof is in the
orange juice as they would say uh but
she was really selling me on nashville
because she absolutely loves nashville
and we sort of agreed okay we're
probably not gonna move either one of us
but like how great it is that we both
decided to live in great places that
line up with our beliefs she lived in dc
now she's in nashville i lived in l.a
now i'm in florida it's like that's what
it's all about and uh there probably
won't be many other cities that i visit
blue cities anymore but i will
definitely visit her in nashville i
think i'm going to go to nashville next
month to tape her show and do a couple
things with the daily wire people
linda says what can americans do if
biden shuts down our funds as they did
in canada
what will these truckers do i mean look
hopefully
hopefully that does not happen now i
don't think it's going to happen in
relation
to the truckers so i don't anticipate
that suddenly joe biden will sign some
sort of executive order that will make
financial institutions have to freeze
bank accounts of free us citizens for
putting a couple bucks into a fund to
help people protest in canada like that
seems completely insane
i don't know how that could possibly be
legal i don't even know that it's like
actually technically doable that being
said we live in a crazy time where it's
like i mean it's like you can wake up
tomorrow and it's like what could they
do that you'd be shocked by right like
every morning it gets stupider
you know every level of the nonsense
like there's so little that could shock
us at like the aliens could land in the
morning and everyone
at 9 00 am they could announce they're
here and by noon everyone would be
fighting over whether they're racist or
not like it's just it's just how the
machine sort of operates in this
it's fast it's 24-hour news cycle isn't
even right it's just this perpetual
motion machine that we're all kind of in
um so i don't think that would happen
that biden would somehow do something to
stop people from funding things but look
if we had a mass protest movement here
in the united states against mandates
would biden do everything he could to
stop it would he call these people
racist would he call them bigots and
islamophobes and all of the other
nonsense that trudeau just did of course
he would right i mean that's what he
calls half the country anyway as he
calls for healing on one hand and then
he calls his opponents bigots and
racists on the other hand so
that's one part of it your second
question which was what will these
truckers do
i i hope and i it's it's very easy for
for me to say from the comfort of my
chair in my studio here in the free
state of florida but i hope they will
not lose
their wherewithal here right i hope they
will calmly
continue to push where they can push and
be as peaceful and upstanding as they
have been and i get it it ain't going to
be easy i mean i said this on the show
yesterday but really really try to think
about it for one moment
if you were in a country
that you felt you had to protest what
what you thought was your free country
right and now you had to protest the
government because they had locked you
down for two years and all of the stuff
right they've done all of this
and then out of nowhere the government
uh the governor or the prime minister
whatever it is
uh says we're gonna freeze your bank
account if we see you out there we might
arrest you if we see out there one of
the things that i saw just about a half
hour before we started taping today they
put out an ottawa official ottawa
account put out a message that if you
are arrested
at one of these rallies
and unable to take care of your pet
because they've arrested you for eight
days they will hold your pet and then
after that they will just put it in a in
a
i don't know i don't put it in what a
pen i don't even know what they do with
it they will just release it or kill it
god only knows what they're gonna do
with it but it's like you get it you get
it like imagine what these people are
truly going through and that's why we
have to support them however we can we
really do because then it could come
here
and that's not even the reason actually
we should support it because it's right
but if you don't support it and then it
comes here you've lost a little bit of
your footing for sure
angel says how's the hair holding up in
florida have you figured out the perfect
concoction of hair products to make it
look suave i'm feeling pretty good about
the hair game these days uh yeah you
know the big fear
the big fear of moving to florida sure
there was the freedom
there was the liberty the choice the
ability to go outside all of those
things but then there was the fear okay
and the fear was that because of the
humidity
and that's what everyone says it's far
it's humid it's a wet heat
la you're getting the dry heat arizona
you get the dry heat dry heat good for
hair height i got to tell you i'm having
no problem with the hair height here i
use the dry texturizing spray that
that puffs it up a little uh super fine
hairspray to keep it in place and
everything's been just fine now we will
revisit this over the summer that's what
people keep telling me dave sure your
hair looks good now but they could come
for it in the summer you know the
stormtroopers and the humidity people
cheryl says it seems as though trudeau
is poking the bear to get the truckers
to strike first in some violent sort of
way do you see any peaceful way out of
this what about the vote of no
confidence that is a way for the
legislative body to censure the prime
minister any chance that could happen so
from what i understand that actually
could happen that basically the entire
legislative body could just say
a vote of no confidence again i've been
relating all of this to the star wars
prequels that's what they did to
chancellor valor right like they can
basically say this guy is just he's lost
it he's not in charge anymore nobody
trusts him and he's out in essence so
there's probably some procedural version
of that that could work um
i sense that basically the next two
weeks are the real defining moment here
right because we had 10 days or so of
peaceful protesting and all trudeau did
was say that these people were racist
all he had to do i mean imagine and
maybe in retrospect if he could go back
he would do it although i'm actually not
sure because i really do think he i
think he's genuinely a psychopath i
really do i think his quest was power
and that really twists you but imagine
if dave were day five into this thing so
we're like a week and a half ago
day five people are out there they're
playing bob marley music they're
cleaning up the streets they're hugging
each other loving on each other it's all
good and imagine if trudeau just showed
up out there and said you know what
he didn't have to wear a jacket he could
just well it's cold out but you know
just like kind of just be like a little
more relaxed justin trudeau and they've
just been out there and just been like
you know what i hear you guys and and
this has been tough on everybody and we
might have made some mistakes along the
way
um but you know we're going to actually
give some of the power back to the local
provinces the towns the cities and let's
see what happens and maybe why don't we
revisit this in a month now maybe it
would have been [ __ ]
maybe that's just not the way politics
works but there was an opportunity there
for something like that to happen
um and he chose instead of instead of
any fig leaf he chose to just move on
them i will use state power on you guys
this is
this is like the type of stuff that we
expect dictators in the middle east to
do you may remember the the revolt in
egypt you know about it what is it about
10 years ago or so now right to rear
square
and and hosni mubarak who is the the
president of egypt in effect a dictator
you know they had sort of fake elections
but he had been an american ally you may
not have liked him you might have liked
them maybe he wasn't as radical as the
muslim brotherhood whatever it is
doesn't even matter but the guy sort of
kept the country going for a long time
then the people started rising up
against him and immediately obama was
the president of time he basically threw
mubarak under the bus mubarak's now dead
and long gone but the point is that he
was cracking down on his own people and
the western world was like no you're
obviously the bad guy okay now what have
they done with trudeau has biden said a
word as i'm taping this right now i
don't think biden has been asked one
question about this right they're
probably hiding biden so they throw sake
out there to just punt the question all
the time but it's like what do western
leaders think of this right now western
leaders every western leader should be
out there having to say do you agree
with this guy
going with emergency powers abusing his
office uh in in the face of peaceful
protest so
i don't know what the off-ramp here is
now he's he ramped up the game and now
what what would be the sensible thing
for him to do well of course it would be
to ramp scale it back i just don't see
it uh leslie says hey dave love
listening to you do you think the cost
of housing especially rentals will come
back down i guess it depends where you
live i mean one of the reasons that i
really wanted to leave la and the reason
that we did it so quickly was it didn't
make sense to me that the cost of
housing kept rising there
because i was like who the hell is
moving to la this makes no sense and
when we put our house on the market we
put it up for a pretty hefty number and
we got offers
we actually barely negotiated and i took
a very early offer and i was just like i
just want to get the hell out of here
like i
actually even gave some money back
because i was just like i just want to
go because my feeling was the market was
going to collapse there at any time it
wasn't that the countrywide market was
going to collapse but it just didn't
make sense to me that say in a place
like la that housing prices would keep
going up but even in even the dystopian
city of san francisco housing prices are
still going up uh so it i don't know
what that's all about a lot of people
have said you know there's
things like black rockers just buying
all of these houses to keep prices sort
of high and ensure that people in the
future just won't own anything uh and
that will all just become endless uh
renters which to me is a huge problem
because if i've done one thing right
financially in my life it's that uh i've
owned three different places and each
one was a stretch for me a major stretch
but i was always able to parlay that
into something better to me i like
owning things you know some people own a
lot of stocks i don't i believe in
owning things there's something like
literally tangible about it and that
allows you to then make the right
decisions when the when the time comes
so look i can tell you in a place like
florida right now there's a ton of
people that want to move here the
market's really high my cousin who's
lived in miami for about 10 years who
lives about 15 minutes away from me now
his rent just got jacked up 70
because of the influx here he's really
not happy about that
and i get it i get it and this is where
this is where you want more building
right you want more competition uh you
want you want less regulation so
builders can come in and innovate and
build more quickly right that's what you
want and fortunately we have some
version of that in florida but it's not
perfect but i really think it depends
where you live if you live in a place
that's flourishing it's sort of tough on
the on the purchase or rental side but
it's probably worth it to stretch
yourself to be there and these places
that are crumbling and the prices are
still high it's like what is really
going on there i don't know i actually
don't know
amy says you have vowed to work to keep
the state of florida free do you have
any plans on connecting with and
potentially promoting candidates running
in local elections such as school boards
or commissioner races yes absolutely
so i don't want to say too much on this
yet uh but i have reached out to a
couple local people here in miami i
really want to get to know uh the mayor
of the specific part of miami that i'm
in it's not i'm not in miami beach with
uh with mayor suarez i wish i was he's
he's awesome and miami beach is pretty
cool uh but i want to reach out to a
couple people i met the deputy mayor
here
because it's it's important actually
this is one of the things in in my next
book that comes out in april it's like
get to know some of your local
politicians they will have far more to
do with your life
than the national politicians at least
in a sane society like if you've got
problems if there are potholes on your
roads like who's going to fix it the
president or the local guy our roads
happen to be pretty nice here like
everything's kept up really nice but i
want to make sure that that stays in
place uh so i've been trying to be out
and about and meet as many people as
possible and i think when i tore for the
book i really i've told my guys i want
to go very heavy in florida and i'll
meet i'll meet the deputy mayors and the
commissioners and the sanitation people
and the guy in charge of alligator
wrestling everybody want to meet them
all
danielle says if you could interview any
alive person and give them some truth
serum right before the interview who
would you pick for the sake of this
question brandon is considered alive
well that was nice of you in light of
the video that we showed at the top here
if i could interview anyone and give
them truth serum i mean
like probably hillary i guess like what
really is going on there did you do the
spying thing did you know about it did
you ever think that trump really was
involved in with russia were you
involved with russia like were you up to
criminal activity what do you know
about bill and all the women and the you
know monica lewinsky and the blue dress
and the cigar and the call
to trent lott and all of the stuff i
guess it would just be interesting
because she's so deeply inauthentic i
know she's not that relevant anymore in
a way although there's some people
saying she's going to run because
they're going to you know they're just
going to cryo freeze biden or whatever
um
but you know someone who's so
inauthentic to get truth serum would be
something like trump like put it this
way if you if you injected trump with
truth serum like i don't think he would
be that different
not because he would be
like any more
like honest but in a way it's like he's
sort of as honest as he can be like he's
a showman and he has the funny affect
and all that kind of stuff but he's
basically telling you the truth
basically right
not to say he isn't exaggerating all the
time and that sort of stuff but hillary
it's like it all seems so deeply
inauthentic that maybe a little
authenticity would be good or what about
kamala can you imagine that i mean this
woman she could not or saki oh there you
go saki's the one forget the hillary one
sake trying to tell the truth
bam brain explosion
candace says thank you dave for pushing
me to leave the dystopian nightmare that
is california congratulations uh second
week of may i'm out can you get shapiro
to donate to your flea cali fund you
know what
well first off now i see why you guys
gave me cash today which i've been told
came out of my wallet which i don't know
why you guys were in my wallet but i'll
just let that be
uh we had some cash here so candace i'm
going to throw in i'm going to throw in
20 bucks for you right now
uh well i can't guarantee that you're
going to get this is the flea cali money
but you're on the list if you're in the
locals community and you tell me you're
leaving cali you're on the list so you
know every time i mention cali on the
show especially gratuitously we throw
some money in here and i'm just going to
give a whole bunch of cash to somebody
at the end of the year to get the hell
out of california and you don't have to
move to florida but i i'm realistically
you're moving apart if i'm giving you
the cash um can i get ben shapiro to
throw in some money i will text shapiro
and i will ask him
should i challenge shapiro
all right
yeah i'm gonna challenge ben shapiro
this is the challenge
to benjamin shapiro okay benjamin you
hear me this is the challenge benny you
left
los angeles about two years ago you left
me there you left me you abandoned me
i stayed for another year it was tough
but then i left
but now i'm raising money
cash
to give to one lucky reuben report
viewer at the end of the year i'm just
going to be throwing cash into this
thing at the end of the year and then
i'm going to throw a couple grand in
extra to just give somebody i'm just
going to hand them a whole bunch of cash
to leave cali and move to florida will
you match
my year-end donation to save someone
from the dystopian horrific city
of los angeles to move anywhere in the
free state of florida will you match me
ben shapiro
we'll find out stay tuned everybody uh
francis says as a new florida resident
besides freedom what have you discovered
here that you enjoy you know what i'm
really loving well first off
seeing the just the trees
the plants everything is so freaking
alive here in l.a you know la was built
basically on a desert they had to move a
whole bunch of water in there you know
you get the palm trees okay fine but
everything is so lush and alive here and
gorgeous in the plants and just going to
home depot and buying stuff for our
backyard like everything just looks
great you touch the plants they feel
like leather like the the just the
leaves are just so thick and dense and
alive i love it but really what i'm
loving are the the animals that we're
seeing everywhere first off i've got
like a gajillion peacocks outside of my
house at all moments and we were walking
clyde i think we've got some b-roll on
this we were walking clyde the other day
and peacock's everywhere he's hunting
down peacocks they make this crazy sound
apparently it's a big uh it's a big
thing here in miami you've got the
peacock the pro-peacock people and the
anti-peacock people some people like
them out there you got to slow down your
car
they can be a little noisy etcetera
etcetera some people think that they we
should kill them uh you know euthanasia
although i don't see what a young person
in china has to do with this and uh that
was corny that was corny i should i
should be doc's pay for that one yeah oh
he liked it um
so
so the peacocks uh clyde's he killed a
couple squirrels he's out there he's
connecting with that with that deep
primal need we're getting dead lizards
showing up at our door had one in my bed
that wasn't great um but just like the
animals and the life just that it just
feels good and i gotta tell you the air
man because it is a little more humid
here like i wake up and i can fully
breathe through my nose and that is
pretty sweet
daniella says i think the durham report
is proving two things hillary is guilty
of concocting the russia conspiracy and
spying on trump's campaign but it also
seems like she is so untouchable that
she will never go to jail for any of it
how can we defeat the machine that
protects her okay so we talked a little
bit about the durham probe earlier in
the week i don't want to fully rehash
that although my offer to jake tapper or
anyone on cnn still stands if you guys
debunk it just debunk the thing instead
of ignoring it i will gladly play the
video i will play it with no added
commentary i'm not kidding i will not
put myself on before or after i will
just mirror it on this channel if you
honestly debunk it i truly mean that
that's number one uh number two yeah
there's a lot of evidence pointing to
hillary right now i mean her campaign
paid a company to spy on trump
headquarters right trump tower
headquarters the office of the
president-elect they paid them to do it
and then biden's campaign paid the same
company in 2020 and then for four years
the media ran with this crazy lie that
trump was somehow either a russian asset
or a russian spy it led to impeachment
etc etc like you guys get all that now
the question really is what you're
getting to is like does anyone pay for
doing bad things anymore right we punish
people for doing good things so if
you're up in canada and you're like hey
i'd like to go to work and go to school
eh
they're going to punish you for that uh
but does anyone get punished if you say
you know basically do espionage on the
incoming president of the united states
it's kind of like no kind of like no the
machine just keeps going and that's why
i always say you have to admire the
machine not for the evil that it does
but for its ability to morph right in
front of our face and make us not
believe what we can see and what just
happened and and how it shifts
narratives i mean it's it's incredible
it's like an undescribable thing you
know it's like asking somebody to
explain the meaning of life it's it's
ephemeral it's almost impossible you
can't you can't it's just it just is
so i don't think even even if they had
v
like email from hillary like spy on
trump in all caps like no nothing really
would happen she would not be arrested
and by the way half the country wouldn't
believe it anyway and cnn would ignore
it and new york times and washington
post would somehow say it was concocted
and we're all conspiracy theorists and
and racists and and the rest of it so i
think the best thing we can do
is hopefully find better candidates to
vote for and hopefully live in places
that are lined up with our values
and and see the nonsense for what it is
and not get too crazy by it which is why
i do this show the way i do it uh
tallway says how do lefties in the u.s
and canada hope to remain in office as
they anger more and more people well i
sort of just answered that question it's
just sort of how the machine operates
and then just flips everything to make
it look like the people who just want to
live and let live and be left alone are
are the bad guys and the racists and all
of that stuff but there really is a push
back there really is guys and i know it
can be hard to see sometimes
but when you see
as i covered yesterday a guy like glenn
younkin who won in virginia because he
ran against woke-ism ran against
critical race theory and you see him
signing a law to ban mask mandates for
kids in schools and then you see the
uproarious joy
of the young girl next to him but the
entire crowd with him and what are they
applauding it's not that they're
applauding that they hate masks so much
they're applauding freedom that freedom
isn't completely dead right it was on
life support for a long time but maybe
it's about to be jolted back into
reality and it's on us to make sure that
that actually
does happen so
do it do you have anything better to do
guys my full interview with maxine
bernier is up on locals right now it'll
be up on youtube and normal in a few
minutes if i'm not mistaken yes that's
right uh my full episode with charlie
kirk is up on locals and of course
that's ad free at
reubenreport.locals.com
have a great weekend everybody oh and by
the way uh next week this is the one
week a year presidents week where my
family my full family brothers sister
parents kids nieces nephews everybody we
all get together for one week we haven't
done it for two years because of kovitz
so i won't have live shows but i do have
one live appearance that we're gonna get
some video of i'm probably gonna do some
uh some videos while i'm just sort of on
location doing my thing but i i will not
be in studio but obviously i can't fully
disappear because there's just so much
going on in the world and we gotta keep
fighting the madness because the madness
is gonna keep fighting us
uh but once again have a good weekend
and i'll see you later bye